before the video starts guys check our
sponsors and nature's blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10
percent of their products what are you
guys waiting for
so brother says I wanted to react to
this specific video and hamdulillah it's
amazing I found it profound it's so
short it's 15 seconds or 10 seconds but
it's such a short video but it speaks
volumes it tells us so much about
tawheed about Allah as a smile was the
farthest names and his attributes and
you know all those aspects you know when
I was watching I was just like this is
amazing this is absolutely amazing I
want us to watch it together in Shalala
get straight to the video this is
absolutely amazing mind-blowing yeah
okay and that's what should together oh
yeah okay here I've got my phone someone
from the screen for you guys yeah okay
here we go
so we follow your side similar so it's
there's a bacteria they've pinpointed
where the bacteria is the white blood
cell and the red blood cells yeah okay
so let's watch and see what happens here
we go okay watch carefully
yeah this is absolutely this is amazing
this here I don't how long would this
video 17 seconds here let's watch it
again look what's happening brother
sisters here the white blood cell is
chasing the bacteria literally chasing
it down through the red blood cells and
boom yes we got him and terminating the
disease to an atheist like an arrogant
if he's know if it's all the same like
allah says in the quran it was that all
christians the same me at least was
aware yeah an old people looking like
the same year this is amazing so
profound think about it if an arrogant
atheist washing cobbler
what's the big deal you know it's
evolutionary process getting on with
what it's doing you know random events
random explosions and a boom pow you
know like you know just random things
that are happening brothers and sisters
when I look at this this confirms so
much to me number one I see order
I see a system I see order I don't see
chaos
I see order I see a white blood cell
chasing down a bacteria to eliminate it
that is order that is functioning order
that's organization that's systemic
that's a plan that's a rather that's
will does it there's been some kind of
will day you might call it it's it's
like some kind of just bacteria but
something so mine it is so small on that
level on a micro level it's actions
happening this is a factory it's it's
movement I don't know how else to
explain it
you can clearly see from that video that
the bacteria is running for its life
it's like a police chase it's literally
like a police chase now I don't know
about you guys but that proof that
confirms to me a creator no shadow of
doubt no shirt over that and that's the
reason why a lot of the times atheist
just cannot get out of it you know with
a new argument that the robbers in the
down we formulated is the continuous
argument which is a very problematic
argument for them they cannot get out of
that do we require a necessary course
why because all of these things require
a necessary existence and necessary
being a bacteria a white cell random
just popped out in the Big Bang boom
exploded and these bacteria said oh hey
how we doing there let me go I mean
these these all these atoms and all
these things in in our atmosphere the
dark matter you know all these things in
our atmosphere imagine look at how is
chasing the bacteria come here fam yeah
it's like a first II bother searching
for a marriage here and that's what a
marriage documentary is coming out
inshallah very soon balan sisters
looking amazing but that's another topic
we don't divert or topic yeah brothers
and sisters
now that shows to us that if that there
is design it requires a designer it not
if that has some kind of power in what
is doing it requires me powerful if that
bear the white zone knows what is doing
and the bacteria knows what he's doing
that she requires and all-knowing
because how could the one who's created
the heavens and the earth create these
and not be very own knowing that
all-powerful
the most wise the most merciful brothers
and sisters this affirms our last
tawheed his oneness his oneness in Rama
be I was single him out in his lordship
and what he does we single him out in
worship because once we affirm
rhombomere that he is the lord of the
heavens and the earth and we sing to him
out all those actions and he does not
need jesus peace be upon him or muhammad
peace be upon him or Buddha
however you want to call it and he does
that him and him alone we then have to
affirm affirm his all here that we
single you out in worship yeah
Buddha were yeah can I stay you alone we
worship and you alone we ask for help
brothers and sisters this is tawheed
this is what the religion has come down
for the main thing and all the problems
that we have around us it all relates
back to a lack of toe heat and that's
something that we discussed in the
marriage documentary and how it ties in
with her own relationships and all kinds
of other aspects of the marriage we're
gonna go in depth but here watching that
bacteria chasing that well I it just
makes you want to go inside Judah while
I prostrate and one lie I mean this from
the bottom of my heart brothers and
sisters you're watching that is so
profound I'm so overwhelmed by it and
brothers and sisters what Allah he those
who can see and I'm not talking with the
ice but with the heart well I hear ya
you cannot see nothing but praise Allah
Subhan Allah Allah look about Al
hamdulillah let you know hey longer but
you have to praise his glory
brothers and sisters if that does not
move your heart if that does not make
you think wow what I hear another Wow
and that we have to say is to our dental
art or what is dead if we cannot look at
that and say subhanAllah amazing and
affirm our last names and his attribute
brothers and sisters what lie in this
video has 17 second video has blown my
mind away and the credit goes obviously
to the brothers who shed in the Hyde
Park group that were in and I found
amazing I wanted to share that reminder
with you guys brothers and sisters and
wallahi it's the oneness of allah
subhanho wa taala and the Shahada comes
with seven conditions first of them is
knowledge borrowing the sisters once you
cannot Ohio the knowledge you implement
it you put it into practice
you have certainty you are truthful to
it you live by it they say that every
vessel sweats what's inside it once
imminent is the heart once you
understand tawheed once you understand
his glory I'm not gonna come here and
tell you to worship I'm not because of
hellfire
why don't you worship Allah for his love
for his mercy for his Rama because over
there that's white so chasing that
bacteria is a Rama from Allah it's a
mercy that I lost putting this things in
our bodies and his place is that when
you get to cut boom it's not a factory
getting get the job get the job going
let's go it's communication even be it's
our DNA prophet says well I'm so I'm
really passionate but what lie
I hope this has moved you guys as much
as it s moves me and we ask Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala because his signs are
everywhere his signs is ayah is not just
in an and the verses now what why he
look around you that's why Allah says in
the Quran in surah anaam verse 1 8 91 90
Alice font Allah says in fe halloki sama
y t1 r OD work till I feel a me when her
Eli Tilly
and indeed in the alternation of in the
creation of the heavens and the earth
and in the alternation of night and day
there are signs for those who have think
wisdom a brain literally pink fink
bombers and sisters what Allah he it was
absolutely mind-blowing
and that's exactly something but I
wanted to share with you guys and what
Allah he I do not know anything else
that I can say and a dois one last thing
I want to share with you guys ball and
sisters is download this app fourth car
yes a lot of people that going for
anxiety depression was wasa do your
morning and evening of car bombs and
sisters and the reason why I'm saying
that is because it has changed my life
and staying up with this and especially
being in the Dow seen evil eye we all
suffer from so I would HIGHLY highly
recommend you guys to inshallah do that
and there's something specifically but I
want to share with you guys inshallah
this is a due process on them
specifically it's for one of your at car
let me just get you guys it okay I think
is this one yes I ready to be laugh here
up will Islam Medina well be Muhammad
sallallaahu leave will send them in the
be and yes it means I am pleased with
Allah is my Lord will stammers my Dean
and the first column as my messenger
there is no Muslim it is an adult
there is no Muslim servant who says in
the morning and in the evening three
times I am pleased with Allah as my Rob
with my Lord and with his thumb as my
religion and with mohammed salah salem
as a prophet except that it will be a
right upon allah to please him on the
day of judgment bothers and sisters get
the app I'll put a link into inshallah
downloaded implement in your life ready
to be lahir up what Bill Islam Edina
why be muhammad sallallahu wasallam
enemy and we are pleased with our Lord
and it's Thomas our Deen and the first
person is a final messenger do not let
the doubts and super hat and the lies
mess with you Iman stay strong wash
bombs in the Dow scene I era of Muhammad
hijab
I'm Sofia I'm you know we are out there
combatting these lies and trying our
best
may Allah bless you guys supporting our
work assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullah wa
barakato